some facebook users can now call for
violence against russian soldiers
they're even allowed to call for
vladimir putin's death that's after the
company tweaked its hate speech policy
in response to the war in ukraine but
what are the consequences this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm adrian
finnegan meta the company that owns
facebook and instagram could soon be
banned in russia as an extremist
organization
the kremlin announced that it's blocking
instagram a move that will affect some
80 million users now this is all in
response to meta announcing a change in
its hate speech policy allowing violent
posts in some instances
there's now a partial exception when the
targets are russian soldiers in ukraine
meta's decision is part of a wave of
corporate action against the russian
invasion of ukraine a spokesman for the
company says that its platforms will
continue to ban violent posts against
russian civilians
well here's part of the statement from
metta's global affairs president nick
clegg he says our policies are focused
on protecting people's rights to speech
as an expression of self-defense in
reaction to a military invasion of their
country to be clear we're only going to
apply this policy in ukraine itself we
have no quarrel with the russian people
so much to discuss let's bring in our
guests for today from london we're
joined by masa ali madani who's an
internet researcher at the oxford
internet institute from preston
lancashire amy bins is senior lecturer
in digital journalism at the university
of central lancashire
and in london tim squirrell head of
communications and editorial at the
institute for strategic dialogue uh
welcome to you all masa let's start with
you our metas changes to its hate speech
policy here a perfectly reasonable
reaction
to russia's actions in ukraine
or something
chillingly dangerous
i mean
i would answer that question by looking
at what kind of precedent meta has in
applying its policies consistently
i mean we have other countries where we
have had russian forces invade we have
the same thing occurring in syria
however this exception has not been made
for syrians i mean there's a host of
countries that can make these kinds of
calls and face these exceptions
armenia
ukraine poland lithuania there's a host
of these countries none of them include
syria so and this is part and parcel of
a lot of policies we see
inconsistencies in the application of
these um another uh
i mean frightening thing to consider is
the fact that why do we want to be
calling um
making threats against russian soldiers
there is i mean this is something the
former united nations special rapporteur
said which is you would want
russian soldiers to have a culture where
they can disaffect and withdraw from
this war not to be further demonized so
it's very concerning what kind of
implications this can have and what kind
of evidence for the benefits this kind
of policy can have amy
meta is effectively
decreeing that some people are just so
terrible that it's okay for us to say
violent and threatening things too and
that it has the power to decide who we
can use such language against isn't it
yeah and i think that's really
interesting point that for very very
many years
um
facebook and the other big social media
companies have avoided regulation on the
grounds that they're just platforms
they're not publishers
uh they're just platforms where people
can go and say whatever they like and
facebook or instagram
or twitter are not responsible for what
people say
but what we're seeing here is facebook
is making an editorial judgment they're
behaving like a publisher just the same
way as a newspaper says
we'll publish this reader's letter and
we won't publish that reader's letter
um so i think in the long term what we
can see is more evidence that these are
not really just platforms at all they
are very large powerful media businesses
and they are publishers making editorial
judgments
tim i i could see you you nodding there
um
is meta meta effectively saying here
that it's it's perfectly reasonable it's
okay to single out people from one
country and one country alone
and gives them the green light for what
amounts to hate speech
what are the implications of that
i think the difficulty here is that this
is uh being reported a result of a
single leak of a single carve out and
facebook meta has historically been
extremely inconsistent in forcing its
policies across different regions um
they've recently become a little bit
better into the western world an
english-speaking world enforcing these
policies but if you look uh for example
my organization's research in in the
mena region you can see that when it
comes to non-english speaking spaces
incitement to violence is
one of the things that happens quite a
lot but there are a multitude of sins
which occur unchecked in these spaces so
it's not necessarily the case that this
is the only exception um and also what
we know is that the more complicated the
policy and the more carve outs they
create the more temporary measures they
create the harder it's going to be to
consistently enforce that in a way
that's actually fair to all its users so
master picking up on on what tim was
saying there was to stop people in other
countries who are also victims of war
calling for them to be allowed to use
hate speech
against
those they perceive as their aggressors
i mean that's a really good question and
i mean i have worked on a particular
case that is similar um in iran in july
2021 we saw protests break out um in
various cities especially in the
province province of khuzestan and
um we had hundreds of cases um from
instagram the most popularly used
platform in iran of takedowns of protest
footage
of people saying death to khamenei who
is the supreme leader in iran and this
is very much a ritualized call it's not
a credible threat of course against um
khamenei's life
but
more a chance
of dissidents amongst the people and so
facebook was removing these posts and so
after going to them with receipts with
evidence of the hundreds of these cases
they came out um and they made an
exception they said for a two-week
period we will allow iranian users to
post death to khamenei um
i mean as advocates we weren't totally
um
uh on board with this change because
death to harmony is kind of an evergreen
chant amongst iranians um but it was
interesting that this was the reaction
and what i do want to know is what were
the you know
like were there advocates bringing
evidence that this was a needed policy
were there actually ukrainians getting
their content removed because they were
making these calls it's interesting to
know and of course like much of the
policies there isn't very much
transparency for the iran case i know
about this because i worked on it myself
um but
it would be interesting to know and to
question why it is that facebook or meta
has been so proactive
on the ukraine case but they had not
been proactive in other crises we we
were seeing the crisis in may 2021 in
palestine when the gaza strip was
getting bombarded
and there was no proactive reaction it
was weeks of activists digital rights
activists palestinian activists coming
with evidence of hundreds of takedowns
of hundreds of different ways that users
were being stimmed and
documenting evidence of human rights
abuses um and um
it and it was after about a two week
period that they came out and said we
are going to have a crisis center for
israel and palestine for for this
situation but with ukraine it was almost
immediate and there should be a lot of
questions about how meta is prioritizing
what it considers crises and who's you
know human rights and who's freedom of
expression that they seem to value more
amy i want to explore some more the
implications for for free speech here
and
control over who can say what and when
this power that the social media giants
yield i mean what are the implications
for free speech should social media
spaces just be a free-for-all should you
be able to say what you want
unrestricted unregulated or should it be
highly policed with penalties for those
who abuse
the social media spaces
and use hate speech on them it's going
to be one or the other hasn't it yeah it
has really um and these companies
all really started up very naively
in california in the home of free speech
with the idea that people are going to
be allowed to say whatever they want
and over time what they found is that
that leads to all kinds of problems it
leads to bullying
uh it leads to
all kinds of terrible things like young
people seeing
images of
anorexia um all kinds of things and it's
so it's become a more regulated space
personally i am in favor of it being a
more regulated space
um i think the idea that
free speech is always a good thing
is a peculiarly american idea
um
and i think that uh inevitably it leads
to to problems as i say of bullying of
increased hatred i think in this
particular case it it doesn't actually
matter that much
we talk about inciting hatred well these
people already hate each other they're
already at war with each other they're
already shooting each other i don't
think allowing people to express that is
actually going to change very much
but generally speaking i'm in favor of
regulation okay but but maybe
but who who is going to regulate we're
talking about about giant american
corporations congress isn't going to
isn't going to legislate against them
again it comes down to
them being allowed to self-regulate and
as we're seeing that just doesn't work
yeah i mean i think you say congress
isn't willing to regulate
but actually what we're seeing even in
america and here in britain and in
australia governments are starting to
look at
regulation at applying law
to uh these social media companies
because they simply have too much power
into in a very very small number of
hands
um so i think what was what we've been
seeing for a number of years now perhaps
three or four years is patients running
out
um governments who are bringing in
regulations against them tim i i can see
you nodding me perhaps you want to come
in on that but but let me put something
to you here donald trump remains banned
from twitter and facebook for inciting
violence ahead of the capital riot uh in
washington dc in january 2021 and here
we have facebook and instagram saying
that it's quite it's fine to incite
violence against vladimir putin and
russian soldiers i mean how do we
explain the double standards there
i think the crucial thing here isn't
necessarily just the double standard but
again the lack of scrutiny and lack of
regulation that facebook and other
social media companies are subject to
here so
we know that there are enormous problems
on these platforms misinformation
weaponized hatred disinformation
extremism calls for incitement to
violence these are running rampant
across these spaces and that's just from
the relatively limited picture of the
information that we do have the fact is
that meta and other social media
platforms just are not subject to the
same degree of transparency regulations
that they should be and so we don't get
to know the extent of the problems and
therefore we don't get to know why
they're making policies in one space and
not another so we don't know what this
particular policy is in response to and
really what matters is that in the
regulations that are forthcoming in the
uk in the eu in australia we need to
have uh
requirements for facebook for instagram
for all of the other companies to be
transparent with their data and allow
researchers access to it so we can see
what's actually going on how they're
affecting society they have a massive
power and they have basically no
responsibility to go with it
muscle
talking of these double standards what
are we to make of of social media
companies sudden moves to take down
russian state content and and channels
um actors who who'd long been allowed to
use their platforms to spread propaganda
and disinformation without sanction are
now suddenly banned they're just gone
right i mean
um
again like husband said a lot of
what's missing is what is
what is the transparency behind the
decision what are the actual costs and
benefits because we're seeing a lot of
discourse a lot of policy a lot of
private companies not just facebook or
meta um you know trying to put sanctions
um you know either lawful sanctions or
just um
self-initiated ones on different russian
entities and the question really has to
be what is the benefit in
um banning these organizations are we
you know losing insight into what these
um
you know institutions are thinking about
um or are we really putting a stop to
rampant misinformation i mean we've seen
companies stop providing internet
services inside of russia we've seen
you know a lot of things that can
potentially have a lot of repercussions
for ordinary russians who in a lot of
cases might not be supporting the war or
or putin's regime and so when you block
these um you know these institutions
from having platforms on facebook what
are the repercussions uh you know we saw
immediately when sanctions were put on
these media companies you know we saw um
like bbc have sanctions we saw a lot of
western media that could be valuable um
be blocked for russian uh people and so
i think it's very important to see what
the actual
um costs are for ordinary civilians when
you are doing these kinds of when you're
putting these policies in place and
right now the biggest cost we're seeing
is the fact that as of monday um
russians are not going to be able to
access instagram um and other
western platforms have been similarly
banned in reaction to these policies so
is it worth it are these policies
actually worth the cost that the russian
people are going to have to pay
amy um to what extent is the kremlin
which over the last decade has become a
master
of disinformation and online subterfuge
to what extent is it now finding itself
um with the tables turned that it that
it seriously risks losing the
information war over its war in ukraine
i think uh the kremlin is cracking down
extremely hard on their own state media
which is where most ordinary russians
get their information from
um so i think in that sense uh they're
winning by essentially disconnecting
from the rest of the world and i think
facebook has given them an excuse to
accelerate that by saying to the russian
people
um these people hate you these people
want to incite hatred against you um you
can't trust them we're getting rid of
them so i think yeah
in a sense we're playing into the into
the kremlin's hands there
um
i think it's quite cynical what they've
done
in that
what facebook has done and that facebook
knows that
if they keep taking down people's
content in ukraine
those people and people in belarus and
the people in the rest of poland
will start moving to other platforms and
if they move to other platforms they
probably won't come back
so i think in some ways because quite a
cynical move a profit motivated move
do you agree with that
so it may well be the case that facebook
is a cynical actor here but i think the
more cynical actor is critically the
kremlin um this is probably a policy
that they wanted to pursue anyway
they've been trying to essentially
militate against facebook from the early
days of this conflict when facebook
started fact-checking some of their
state-run media organizations and so
this has given them absolutely an excuse
to do it probably earlier than they
would have done but they were already
looking for a reason to shutter uh
facebook and and similar outlets where
you can gain access to
information which doesn't come from uh
pro kremlin sources in russia so they
are effectively trying to win the
information war on the ground with their
own people by shuttering independent
media by restricting access to social
media platforms where you might be
exposed to some other ideas that aren't
programming narratives and allowing um
to continue operating places like
telegram where rt and sputnik and other
russian state-owned media operations
have a massive footprint and where
they're able to spend their spread
disinformation without much fear of
regulation
i want to get your thoughts on on that
too with with this ban on
more mainstream social media than
twitter instagram and the introduction
also of stiff penalties for anyone
declared to be spreading uh false news
uh is the kremlin basically trying to
outlaw information
and will it succeed
um i mean it's part and parcel of a lot
of their efforts for a sovereign
internet i mean we've been seeing leaks
of uh potential regulations that are
going to be nationalizing their internet
in reaction to a lot of this um in
reaction to potential uh
fears of sanctions stop it stopping
actual internet uh international
internet connections to russia as well
so
um and these uh like was mentioned are
have been policies that russia has had
long standing has been discussing for a
while um i mean the role of telegram
here is very interesting um it's a very
controversial platform both in terms of
um you know what exactly
the security
guarantees are for its users but in
terms of you know its content moderation
policies and and by that i mean its lack
of content moderation uh policies that
allows for a lot of um actors that have
been de-platformed by the mainstream
platforms to come and find their voice
and their audience there
um so i think as we go forward
it's going to be interesting to see how
telegram's role in this conflict is
going to shape up i mean we've already
seen the founder come out and say that
he guarantees
security
and a place for ukrainian users
despite the fact that there has been
rumors that you know telegram might have
interest to cooperate with the with
kremlin um
so
and as of monday it will be the only uh
social media platform that won't be
banned in russia seeing that most
facebook platforms meta
and twitter will be banned
okay um amy i just want to ask you as a
digital journalism uh lecturer um
about how you think that this war has
been covered online
it is being played out in real time
online you can follow it 24 hours a day
seven days a week um
things like the open source intelligence
gatherers who are debunking uh many
russian claims for instance you can
watch all of that going on in real time
what do you make of that
it's fascinating to watch um
i mean obviously it's distressing to see
what's
what we're looking at here
but the way the information is flowing
is absolutely fascinating the way we're
seeing
also
the clock being rolled back so we can
actually see the previous digital
footprint of some of these people
so i'm thinking here about uh the
pregnant lady who was photographed in
the maternity hospital
um and immediately russia is saying
she's a crisis actor
she's an instagram star who runs beauty
business now the interesting thing was
that was actually true
she had previously been on instagram as
an influencer
um
but she wasn't a crisis actor
she was an ukrainian woman who blogged
about being pregnant and who now was in
that maternity hospital
um when uh when that bomb hit
so immediately then people were
debunking and saying well yes she is
this beauty blogger so i think what
we're seeing is
uh this is happening in the place that
is already very switched on to me yeah
yeah um so we're seeing things
responding very quickly and amy i'm
sorry to cut you off i want to get one
last word from from tim here on on that
note tim about
the switched on population i just want
to get your thoughts on how ukraine's
president is doing with his use of
social media to what extent is he
leaving president putin looking old and
out of touch with the fact that he's
vlogmas he's everywhere on social media
right now
i think we have to bear in mind that um
vladimir zelinski may be everywhere on
social media in the west but this isn't
a fight that is just being one or four
in the west it's also one that crucially
has been fought um domestically in
russia because this invasion can only
continue so long as putin remains
popular and so long as you know the body
bags don't start coming back in such a
high level that uh russia has to think
again about what it's doing so it may be
that zolensky is very popular here and
his social media game is pretty strong
um but in addition to that we're seeing
that putin is continuing to create a
stranglehold on information in russia
but i also think that the russian
propaganda game or the kremlin
propaganda game here is is again also
quite strong so you can see for example
in response to this latest thing from
meta
that russia is all the kremlin is
pushing
the
russian lives matter which is a cynical
repurposing of a social justice slogan
from from sort of western social justice
movements um to try to make the claim
that russians and russian speakers are
being victimized both in ukraine and
elsewhere
and that was part of the narrative or
the justification that putin gave for
the war in the first place so it may be
the case that uh ukraine is is putting a
pretty strong fight in the propaganda
war um but i wouldn't count the kremlin
out yes okay there i'm afraid we're
going to have to leave it fascinating
discussion uh really appreciate uh you
taking the time to be with us today masa
ali madani amy bins and tim squirrel
thanks very much indeed
as always thank you for watching don't
forget you can see the program again at
any time just by going to our website
you'll find that aljazeera.com
and for further discussion join us on
our facebook page we'll at facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story and you
can join the conversation on twitter our
handle at aj inside story from me adrian
finnegan and the whole team here in doha
thanks for watching i'll see you again
bye
[Music]
you